here comes the big one best picture of
the year the final award of the year was
to have been presented by mr. and mrs.
Cary Grant but they've gone into an
independent production I think it's
wonderful how a man his age can take up
a whole new line of work and show
results
they couldn't be here tonight they
couldn't get a sitter happily one of
movie's most versatile leading men and
an Oscar winner himself is here film
fans here's film favorites Jack Lemmon
actually I volunteered to sit for Kerry
but you know how nervous new fathers
well you're a brand and father yourself
and you're not nervous of course not
just Danny and Oscar I throw it over my
shoulder birth one end powder the other
right well now Robert before we continue
with this would you come here for just a
second none of this is on the program
and it may be a little bit of a surprise
to you author Robert as great as this
next award is this may be just as
important Arthur freed our president
wishes to speak to you
motley ever serious moments as surely as
clearly evident that you occupy a
special place in the affections of three
men everywhere the Academy now wishes to
express not only our affection but our
continuing gratitude for your continuing
service to us the Board of Governors has
voted to present you with the first gold
medal ever awarded by this Academy
the inscription Leeds agreed to by both
four unique and distinguished service to
our industry
this you couldn't tip me or anything huh
of course not steady and jamming I've
talked with my idiot cards down
I want to tell you I know that Julie
Christie was all cracked up but I'm not
a girl I think I'll cry too now that is
a beautiful thing and it's got a little
Oscar and how much do you think it cost
to pump that kid up seriously I
appreciate this very much and I shall
treasure this and I want anybody who
wants to look at this can come to my
place and it'll be in the shrine thank
you all you remembers the Academy thank
you